most of the success that we've had now
in protecting the rainforest and and and
it's the levels that we've reached are
so far I think back to those Barefoot
days of catching snakes with JJ and the
boat and now the massive Ecological
Reserve we have and the team of Rangers
and the converted lagers and all of that
is because of
the ability to communicate and to show
people but that's all been through
social media and so I'm open to the fact
you know if if somebody came and gave a
sort of like bourdainian pass where they
said look you can be yourself you can
swear you can fart you can smoke you can
do whatever you want to do go out there
and show us the real thing I would love
to but now I know how those contracts
need to be I need to have a right to
refusal and they can't change them and
so I'd almost rather just do it like the
way I think like Mr Beast does stuff
where it's like you just you get a crew
guys and some seed money and go film the
episodes and put it out exactly I mean a
committee never helped real art be
better it has to come from the the the
source of inspiration so you get you I
think you know you get JJ and a crew of
people or the guys in Africa that I'm
working with right now do an elephant
conservation and like
but you gotta show real I mean look
that's why that's why I mean look that's
why Joe Rogan isn't is is important
right now that's why you're important
right now is because it's not being
filtered through
this ridiculous system of of polishing
it and dumbing it down and yeah that's
why Joe has been an inspiration you
don't need a a crew of a bunch of people
you don't need a crew period and all you
need is
one or two other people and that's it in
my case you don't need anybody I've been
doing this uh I by requirement I just
need to be by myself there's a few other
folks now that help with the editing and
so on but it's just they make life more
awesome as opposed to a boss that's that
tells like a creative director yeah
somebody told me actually I was visiting
La I think it was in LA they were saying
that um now for all intimate scenes and
Hollywood movies there's an intimacy
director so when there's a uh two people
having sex there's a third person that
ensures that uh on film so it's not real
but there's still intimacy uh that
there's a third person that ensures that
like everyone is comfortable and the
actors say that this like always ruins
the the chemistry of the scene yeah and
so I just it's a very Hollywood thing I
understand there's creepy people I still
understand uh thanks Harvey wines uh and
it's usually I think comes from the
director pushing things too hard if you
just leave it to the actors they know
their boundaries they can't control
their own boundaries uh so the intimacy
director is more for the like the
director pushing thing you know there's
Warner Herzog I understand I understand
the logic like let's make sure that we
don't have anything happen here that
shouldn't be happening I get it but I
yeah
but but no I think that authenticity is
is is the greatest currency and I think
that in order for me to tell the stories
that I can tell like you know what
changed the game for me was I want to
tell you this story sure so in 2019
um
that the Amazon fire started popping off
and we had just gone to to film uh like
a month earlier we'd filmed like a small
documentary and uh they'd been following
me as if I was on a as if I was on a
solo which you know we did the best we
could I let I lived on my own but we as
we were driving we passed a spot where
the Flames were 70 feet tall the forest
was being destroyed and I went out there
with my phone which overheated in like
two minutes and said you can't use it
but for a second I was out there in the
Flames picking up animals and throwing
them off to try and just get them cooled
off I was trying to get snakes out of
there everything was the birds are
flying and I [__] lost it I I was
red-eyed I was crying and I was going
this is happening every [__] day I
was screaming and it's the first time
that I'd done that because I've seen the
burning so many times and I just lost it
that day and I don't know what made me
pull out my phone because usually in
those intense moments I I say forget the
documentation this is real life we got
stuff to do and I'm doing I'm not
documenting and then a month later I'm
home and I'm in New York and all of a
sudden I see these articles like you
know the Amazon's burning worse this
year than it was last year and blah blah
blah and I was like this you know
[__] and I threw it up on Instagram
like eight o'clock at night
and I'd never like I'd never cursed on
Instagram I don't know you know why I
just never did and I my phone was on 100
and I put it on top of the refrigerator
and I went to bed and I woke up in the
morning and my phone was on the floor on
two percent and it was ringing off the
hook
and it was like the news and they're
like are you the guy that posted that
viral video about the Amazon and I was
like what yeah and that was the start
that's where it broke and that's where
we went from Barefoot in the Amazon to
you know all of a sudden you know I was
talking head for three weeks and going
around on all these news stations and
all of a sudden I was like the
spokesperson for the Amazon and JJ's
calling me and he was like go go go go
go go like get us get us that support
and it was just
um
you know so so communicating with people
and bringing them into that reality and
whether it's you know Rhino poaching and
elephant poaching or the Amazon being
destroyed it's like to me it's like
being able to to to take people into
that is is something that I would love
to do yeah and you do it directly with
authenticity on your Instagram people
should definitely follow your Instagram
I think I think Rogan follows your
Instagram too well the end of that story
actually kind of involves him because
yeah because because I went to all these
news outlets and I was living in green
rooms and traveling around and I was all
strung out and I hadn't seen anybody I
actually know in a few weeks which was
starting to get to me and I finally got
home and I went to like a family party
and everyone's like dude you've been
it's been crazy and I was like yup and
then I left and my cousin Michael calls
me and he's screaming and I'm going what
what what what and he goes Joe Rogan
just shared it Joe Rogan just shared it
oh nice and everyone was losing their
[__] and it was so amazing and it was
like
yeah that's when it really took off and
what happened as a result of all of this
is that a Canadian entrepreneur who
started light speed
um reached out and uh several months
later after covet after that boom
you know I'd been in the game for maybe
13 years or something had no money no
savings no job no nothing and after that
great publicity thing
nothing happened
the waves came and everything got real
exciting everybody reached out and they
said we care so much
nothing happened though you know we can
run into battle but if we don't have our
arrows in the quiver
what can we do
and I actually I made a phone call to my
friend most and right at the start of
covid and I was going through divorce
and I was broke
and I said
I'm gonna get a job
I said I give up
so this is stupid I said the ecotourism
business has done jungle Keepers has
dried up
we're done and then this guy daxed a
Silva called me on the phone and said
listen I'm in what what do we got to do
and so if if the analogy was me and JJ
and a few other people trying to hold
this Boulder back from just destroying
the rainforest all of a sudden Dax comes
in like a Titan and just puts his arm
out and just goes I'm gonna help
and he gave us the funding to start
actually developing a ranger program to
start actually bringing loggers to be
Protectors of the forest to be
supporting smaller conservation things
and now we're protecting 50 000 Acres of
rainforest we're protecting entire
streams and ecosystems that I love and
we're soon going to double that and it's
like this this whole thing so
um yeah the the the the the
communication of these things is crucial
and I actually think it's incredible
that that social media has played such a
big role in it well I mean uh just
because I I know Joe well and I love him
so much I I definitely think
um you should do his podcast but also
just be friends with him I think you
guys
um he's one you know not the meme but
he's one with nature and not much more
with the I'm one while I do appreciate
and love nature I also love
um technology I know yeah and robots and
so on so we're in that Meme type of way
we're very very different but well
either way at some point make sure you
tell the guy thank you because it
definitely really helped push us over
that that limit where you know if enough
people see it you get someone like Dax
who who who says I can help and I have
the resources to help
and that and that changed our whole
lives She's Everything